I’m Neutron, Developer of Erudite
Erudite is a mobile language learning app integrated with all essential tools
including dictionaries, phrasebooks, flashcards
and supports Android Wear
so users can learn English anywhere anytime with their native tongue
Users who speaks English can also learn 24 foreign languages with Erudite
It’s our approach to break the language barrier
and bridge the gap between different cultures
We took Google's suggestion
and updated the app with Material Design
This made our user rating in Google Play increased from 4.1 to 4.3
Erudite now has over 1M downloads globally
with users from more than 200 countries
It has been selected as the Editor's Choice and App of Year 2015 on Google Play
All these acknowledgements also encouraged us a lot
My name is Benji, Product Manager of Erudite
Maintaining user retention is our key priority
We implemented Pre-Launch Report
to collect data from a variety of Android devices
so we can reduce as many bugs as possible before its official release
This helps us to improve user satisfaction
and our user retention rate has increased by over 60%
Firebase enables us to monitor analytics
crash reporting, and other app-specific data
including location, age, gender, device type, etc.
Firebase enables us to know our users from different aspects
and hence make quicker decisions and better app
Additionally, we use Review Analysis
to gather feedback from users on Google Play
and use them to polish Erudite's features
It also allows us to reply to users directly and individually
so we can improve the communication with our users
and know their true requirements
Google is the bridge connecting Erudite and its users from all around the world
I’m Winson, Erudite’s Technical Manager
Google’s great support all along the way makes us more confident about the future
We are trying to build a crowdsource platform
to enable users to contribute learning materials to each other
and providing our users with richer language learning experiences